do you think Trump should have been
removed from Twitter no what's the
what's the pro case can you I'm having
fun here he's still me on each side yeah
um
let's deal man to get him off the
platform
here we have a guy
who
um is virulent in all ways
he promotes confrontation
um he locks decorum he
incites the fervent Believers of his
cause
to act up and push the boundaries
bordering on and potentially even
including breaking the law
he does not observe the social norms of
a society that keep us well-functioning
including an orderly transition of power
if he is left in a moment where he feels
trapped and cornered
he could behave in ways that will
confuse the people that believe in him
to act in ways that they so regret
that
um it could bring our democracy to an
end or create so much damage or create a
wound that's so deep it will take years
of conflict and years of Confrontation
to heal it
we need to remove him and we need to do
it now it's been too long we've Let It
Go on too long
the other side of the argument would be
he was a duly elected person whose views
have been run over for way too long
and he uses the ability to say extreme
things in order to showcase
how corrupt these systems have become
and how insular these organizations are
in protecting their own class
and so if you really want to prevent
class Warfare and if you really want to
keep the American dream alive for
everybody we need to show
that the First Amendment the
Constitution the Second Amendment all of
this infrastructure is actually bigger
than any partisan view no matter how bad
it is and that people
um will make their own decisions
and there are a lot of people that can
see past the words he uses
and focus on the substance of what he's
trying to get across and more generally
agree than disagree and so when you
silence that voice
what you're effectively saying is this
is a rigged game and all of those things
that we've told we were told were not
true are actually true
if you were to look at the crude
algorithms of Twitter of course I don't
have any Insider knowledge but I could
imagine that they saw
the let's say there's a metric that
measures how negative the experiences of
the platform and they probably saw uh in
several ways you could look at this but
the presence of Donald Trump on the
platform was consistently increasing how
shitty people are feeling uh short-term
and long term because they're probably
yelling at each other having worse and
worse and worse experience if you even
do a survey of how do you feel about
using this platform over the last week
they would say horrible relative to
maybe a year ago when uh Donald Trump
was not actively Tweeting or so on so
here you're sitting at Twitter and
saying
okay I I and I know everyone's talking
about speech and all that kind of stuff
but I kind of want to build a platform
where the users are happy
and they're becoming more and more
unhappy how do I solve this happiness
problem well let's
ban let's let's uh yeah let's ban the
sources of the unhappiness now we can't
just say you're a source of unhappiness
so we'll ban you let's wait until that
Source says something that we can claim
uh breaks our rules like insights
violence or so on that would work if you
could measure
your construct of Happiness properly the
problem is I think what Twitter looked
at were active commenters and got it
confused for overall system happiness
because for every piece of content
that's created on the internet of the
hundred people that consume it maybe one
or two people comment on it and so by
over amplifying that signal and assuming
that it was the plurality of people
that's where they actually made a huge
blunder because there was no scientific
method I think to get to the answer of
de-platforming him and it did expose
this idea that it's a bit of a rigged
game and that there are these deep
biases
that some of these organizations have to
opinions that are counter to theirs and
to their Orthodox view of the world
so in general you lean towards keeping
um
first of all presidents on the platform
but also
controversial voices all the time I
think it's really important to keep them
there